in office but there's still some more
chess uh White to play made into this is
a puzzle for our viewers let's see how
quickly you can get it I'm gonna start
the timer now okay
not so easy yeah
so imagine choose you can usually find
by processor of elimination
um okay let me see is there is it
zooke's worm that could be
there's it's sometimes this in these
cases
so
let me try and
I'm trying to think yeah
I'm assuming it's not a check first of
all
it usually isn't no in such puzzles no
that's
like the terms that I'm that I can't
solve this is usually because it's a
it's uh it's a check on the first moment
it didn't didn't occur to me
oh wait a sec wait a second
[Music]
a minute down a minute down yeah usually
uh time pressure no no
I just wanna I just wanna solve it
I don't I don't really care about the
time
if it's any consolation David said this
is one of the hardest made in twos
okay
so I gotta consider every
and remove
ah
are you sure
no but I mean once I saw the move I
thought it
it's hard to be yeah but Queen D4 takes
away the D4 Square so rookie three is
made otherwise it's Knight D6 or Knight
C5 is that it is that your final answer
I mean are you trying no yeah that is my
final answer
actually it's actually typical of these
puzzles so what's the world Champion's
thought process while solving this how
do our viewers get to this yeah I was
just looking at all sorts of different
moves and then I was trying you know
um
trying to to look for sort of weird
moves and once I saw Queen AIDS I I knew
it has to be the solution and uh I mean
the only like um
uh sort of half difficult movies
rookie three otherwise it's
otherwise yeah it's just night night
check
nice